[Musik]
hallo
hallo herzlich willkommen heute auf
englisch herzlich willkommen so salis
welt wir stehen wir da draußen die sonne
ist da und es ist wirklich perfekt denn
gestern habe ich mir vorgenommen heute
mal wieder zu grillen es gibt chili con
carne aus dem grill und brot sticks die
machen wir heute das wird lecker klar
kann man das gericht auch drinnen
zubereiten aber wir haben gedacht wenn
man schon eine art doppel hier haben
gibt dann jetzt natürlich raus das team
freut sich schon mega drauf und das
erste was ich tatsächlich tun werde ist
ein grill anzuzünden der braucht eine
halbe stunde ungefähr bis sie auf
temperatur ist und in der zeit kann ich
alles andere vorbereiten ich habe hier
unser blick rieneck und ich habe hier
noch ein bisschen alte kohle drin das
ganze reduzieren ja es kommt immer mal
jemand rein und raus lkw-fahrer die post
das ist so so ist es bei uns ich habe
hier so ein bisschen rest kohle drin die
lasse ich darin die schiebe ich einfach
zur seite für kurz die kohle auf dann
nämlich auch immer die original kohle
muss ich sagen beim grillen sollte sie
auch generell darauf achten eine gute
kohle zu nehmen die rust nicht und die
riecht auch nicht stark und es sind
immer große und kleine bestandteile drin
damit sie sich gleichmäßig aufwärmt
wirklich die hitze auch hält und man
eben schön kriegen kann
[Musik]
schön verteilen und die drei kilo
erkenne ich daran ich finde es einfach
auf bis zu dieser ersten linie wo die
beschriftung ist und gleichmäßig
verteilen man sieht auch schön große und
kleine stücke das ist perfekt und es
auch eine 100% naturbelassener
grillkohle finde ich auch wichtig und
auch in einem keramik grill wirklich
keinen grillanzünder verwenden keine
chemikalien
das wird nämlich alles in die keramik
beschichtung aufgesaugt werden und
deswegen nehme ich einfach so ein leiter
damit klappt das echt ganz gut ist ein
gerät das echt nicht teuer ist und damit
bekomme ich die grillkohle gut an ich
heiße jetzt hier einmal rein und warten
bis es brennt und der rest macht der
grill dann von alleine
[Musik]
geschafft jetzt verschließe ich hier
alles öffnen hier alle öffnungen
damit sauerstoff drankommt und die kohle
gleichmäßig anfängt zu brennen und in
der zwischenzeit mache ich schon mal ein
brot
ja ich mir gedacht mach' ich mir schon
von mir den 6 dann haben nämlich ein
schnelles brot und ich kann damit später
schöne postings zu bereiten direkt vom
grill
76 ein bisschen hefe und wasser sie
könnte aber auch einfach brot rezepte
von meinem kanal nehmen da habe ich ja
auch schon einige
war auch habe ich jetzt einfach die
verpackung einmal so komplex ist aber
egal
jetzt schön alles draußen in der natur
den teig kneten
eigentlich für zehn minuten ich guck mal
ob ich zehn minuten lang nähte oder ein
bisschen kürzer
[Musik]
das weiß ich wieder warum ich hebe tagen
nicht knete nicht mehr per hand ist es
einfach anstrengend aber es hat auch was
meditatives
nur nicht bei 40 grad aber es
ist ein schönes rocken roggenmischbrot
mit haferflocken
ich finde das passt wird so schön
rustikal also tages geknetet den denke
ich jetzt ab und lasst den einfach hier
unten ja unter dem tisch
kurz ruhen und wohl schon mal die
zutaten von drinnen für mein chili
dann geht es direkt ans chili con carne
hackfleisch habe ich noch in der küche
stehen das steht noch kurz kühl 800
gramm hackfleisch dann brauche ich zwei
zwiebeln 2 knoblauchzehen oder eine
riesige knoblauchzehe
paprikaschoten rote hier habe ich noch
eine stille schote damit so ein bisschen
scharf wird etwas salz und pfeffer dann
habe ich noch einen teelöffel
kreuzkümmel und eine prise zimt ein
bisschen schokolade das sind 40 gramm
zartbitterschokolade für den geschmack
olivenöl tomaten aus der dose oder
nämlich einfach tomaten stücke des sind
es 1200 gramm und etwas meisters der
dose und kidney bohnen dessen so die
typischen zutaten für chili und was
jetzt machen werde ich kann jetzt
erstmal die zwiebeln und die
knoblauchzehe schneiden und dann schälen
und dann fein hacken
alles schön wir
selbst hier draußen sind die zwiebel
dämpfer immer noch stark ich habe
gedacht das versteht sich bisher
zwiebeln habe ich
da heißt auch schon ganz ordentlich aber
braucht noch kurz dann schneide ich
solange die paprikaschoten
[Musik]
jetzt ist mein grill perfekt auf
temperatur ich habe hier oben und unten
die fächer so ein bisschen verschlossen
da kann ich ja die temperatur ein
bisschen fein justieren ich spiele jetzt
ungefähr bei 200 grad wenn ich hier das
fach ein bisschen öffne wird es wieder
heiß oder grillen wenig zweiter schließe
dann fällt die temperatur und so hält
der grill wirklich die temperatur
optimal ich habe jetzt hier auch schon
mein gusseisen topf drin und zwar auf
direkter flamme und da kann ich jetzt
das olivenöl reingeben um ein hack
fleisch anbraten so wie daheim auf dem
kochfeld kann ich das eben hier auch
benutzen und schön meine röstaromen
erzeugen
das ist eigentlich wie am herd kochen
erstmal die röstaromen erzeugen und
später dann bei niedriger stufe schön
weiter gang als ich lasse zimmer 23
minuten dann kommen gleich die zwiebeln
und die knoblauchzehen dazu und was ich
auch noch machen werde das ist
gerösteten knoblauch das hätte ich jetzt
fast vergessen skizziert drei
knoblauchknollen also die sind wirklich
im ganzen die comments ein kleines
häppchen
und da gebe ich olivenöl dazu
ruhig ordentlich dazu
da die töpfchen verschließen und mit
rein stellen
[Musik]
man hört schon das knistern das bedeutet
dass fleisch ist soweit
jetzt können die zwiebeln dazu
[Musik]
kurz verrühren und dann schön mit röcken
für etwa fünf minuten
gut
beim öffnen des grills immer darauf
achten erstmal kurzen kleinen spalt und
dann komplett öffnen wo es sieht super
aus und riecht sogar sehr sehr schön ja
und jetzt ist perfekt christus kommt ja
einfach die übrigen zutaten dazu
sich hier schön die tomaten aufgießen
die gewürze salz pfeffer
das ist
doch ein bisschen wasser dazu das könnt
ihr jetzt mal eine weile
und die bohnen und dem 1 das gebe ich
jetzt noch dazu
sehr gut
[Musik]
am besten untersetzung und
dem schuhtick knobloch aus
dass er ist fertig
das sieht perfekt aus den stelle ich
einfach hier unten kurz ab
sagt ich bin größte doppelter knoblauch
das ist
dann freue mich jetzt kurz alles ab die
schokolade darf später nicht vergessen
die kommt praktisch die ist schon
geschmolzen in der sonne dicken
praktisch als zusatz noch mit rein das
rundet den geschmack ab und ich kann
jetzt hier mein chili etwa eine stunde
köcheln lassen ich werde allerdings ein
bisschen nach oben setzen im kollektor
wahrscheinlich sogar ein damit einfach
die dass chili con carne eben nicht zu
sehr kocht sondern eher logging und der
konrektor des praktischen einsatz der
mir ermöglicht so ein bisschen indirekt
zu kochen nicht auf direkter flamme das
habe ich jetzt gemacht für die
röstaromen und jetzt möchte ich einfach
dass mein chili con carne leicht ein
köchelt und wirklich langsam vor sich
hin gab so dass sich der geschmack und
die aromen perfekt miteinander
kombinieren und das ganze später richtig
richtig
lecker wird wolltest dich lieb wenn ich
so eine richtig schöne moderat sind
macht haben unser am ende habe ich
[Musik]
das chili durfte jetzt ungefähr eine
stunde köcheln jetzt kann ich schon mal
das brot zu bereiten
sieht super aus
guck mal da
es sonst an grill macht nichts
und ich nehme jetzt einfach ein bisschen
hartweizengrieß oder maisgrieß könnt ihr
nehmen so ein bisschen ausrollen
[Musik]
man könnte damit theoretisch auch
stockbrot machen
und so wenn ihr mal stockbrot machen
wollt dann könnt ihr das echt so mit dem
boot backmischungen machen denn dann
habt ihr schon verschiedene sorten
ich mache mir als kleine portionen
jetzt so ein bisschen flach drücken
immer mal meist kriegs dazu nehmen
ja wir machen solche sticks
ich glaube das wird richtig schön und
lecker
doch einfach so eine rolle machen
und dann flach treffen
ich finde so ein paar tipps können eure
kinder machen dann macht es da draußen
einfach umso mehr spaß
und vor allem gibt es jetzt hier können
richtig oder falsch sind die brust iks
die dürfen so ein bisschen christi
kahlos sehen gut das reicht jetzt
erstmal für ein anfang dann hole ich
jetzt mein chili raus wunsch stellt
einfach kurz da unten ab denn der
gusseisen top speichert ja auch die
wärme das heißt wird jetzt auch nicht so
schnell kalt
und warm
es duftet richtig gut
[Musik]
gerade nicht vergessen
und hier kommt jetzt alles drauf
und das brot grillstand hier jetzt oder
backe ich besser gesagt auf den pizza
stein den lasse ich ganz kurz warum
warten und wisst ihr wir prüfen können
ob der stein die temperatur hat ergibt
einfach ein bisschen kriegs drauf
und dann schaue ich gleich wenn sie die
farbe verändert ich sehe ich wenig warm
wird
[Musik]
ich war gerade drauf ich heize hat den
peter stein auf um rustikale brust ich
glaube meine zuschauer kennen dich gar
nicht
frankie
ist wieder da
er war ja nie weg ihr habt ihr nur nicht
sehen im hintergrund im hintergrund
ja heute gibt es chili con carne und
trotzdem sehr gut das ist richtig
sommerlich aus gefällt mir ich meine
passion zum bedrucken ja do for good mir
geht's so
stabil gezeigt
sie mag den habe ich halt auch noch
nicht gesehen ist ja richtig komisch
geworden bei uns weil überall sitzt
jemand und ich sehe nicht alle ihr
vermisst mich nicht weil ihr mich jeden
tag schneidet
videomaterial aber ich vermisse euch
immer
bleibt zu werfen ich würde aber so spät
noch spielt das seht ihr anfangs anfangs
haben wir alle gesagt wir essen wir
trinken das kommt alles weg und jetzt
muss ich immer betteln dass jemand zum
essen bleibt nämlich spaß gibt genug
aber ich wollte das break aber das
nächste mal wirklich dann sage ich
früher gestellt so ich glaube jetzt ist
soweit ich mache jetzt mal bewusst ich
ja fußball wie sagt
frank meine damen und herren
sehr gut das kommt jetzt hier drauf denn
mein weg rieneck also dieser grill ist
im prinzip auch ein backofen da könnt
ihr wirklich schön drin backen ich mache
jetzt mal vier zum testen und
dann traurig die truppe zusammen dann
wird probiert
[Musik]
gucken wir mal nach dem roten die sehen
es gut aus glaub ich
es sehe gut aus die sind richtig gut aus
ich glaube das wird jetzt gleich allen
schrecken also heute lasse ich probieren
den einzigartigen wundervolle
unverwechselbaren
morath und aldi
natives neubau und dann hat er noch
nicht fehlen er macht gerade sein
praxissemester für marketing und
management richtig genau und hier haben
den alten 15 jahre für haiti kommt
einfach ein praktischer weil er möchte
man designer werden oder möchte von den
besten lernen also nicht von mir und
wenn da gar nichts von mir aber wir
können zusammen essen
naja dann probier mal und die wahrheit
sagen und das ja und job verlieren das
ist angst hat dass wir morgen seinen job
verliert ok ich hab' chili con carne mal
okay gut sticks dazu unsere richtig
geniale gerösteten knoblauch den muss
ich tatsächlich noch ganz gut fertig
machen und zwar da nehme ich jetzt
einfach die schale ab
guckt mal der knoblauch ist es richtig
schön
weich gegart und es regt echtes wunder
fall
die märkte nur eins im leben du mich
heiraten geht und ganz ganz wichtig ja
so mit der maus
und als marketing management mache
einfach das was seine frau sagen ob
die milch dass genau hier noch salz
pfeffer rein und dann ist der gerettete
knoblauch fertig
bestimmt fleischwolf also sorry ich
wollte ja zuerst chili sin carne machen
ohne und wollte nichts sagen und das
habe ich doch chili con carne wer hat
schon den knoblauch ich glaube denen
mache ich also schon aufs brot
okay das passt das team probleme zuerst
wenn nichts passiert dann bekomme ich
auch genau das müssen immer hier die
studenten und die praktikantin
vorstellen und schöner ist ja passt auf
dass dich nicht verbrennen
ich war früher übrigens auch mal so wie
du bist ich geheiratet habe
gross war ich auch ja ja sag ich ja
heiraten 30 kilo zugenommen und
geschrumpft
zugenommen mit dem ersten geschrieben
aber
wirklich ehrlich sein
und ja nicht sagen schmeckt wie bei mama
dann irgendwann
haben wir tabaksteuer mal probieren das
ist knoblauch fotos echt
gut ich probiere alles
aber nicht mehr dass sie nicht mehr zur
schule gehe ich jetzt gern ich sags ja
macht da alles fertig
warum ich zugenommen habe
[Musik]
aber nur heiß wird sagen wir holen jetzt
noch die anderen dazu dann ist das echt
ein riesentopf chili con carne und das
reicht für die ganze für die ganze felix
reiches münchens für 15 leuten ja also
wie gesagt heutige rezept könnt ihr
entweder ganz klassisch in eurer küche
auf dem herd zu bereiten das chili con
carne einfach dort rösten und später im
backofen oder auf dem herd bei niedriger
stufe weitergaben das brot geht auch im
backofen aber ich muss sagen sondern
outdoor köchelt es schon auch was cooles
und ihr könnt wirklich alles draußen
machen weil das big green egg einfach
ein grill ist es ist ein kochtopf es ist
ein backofen es ist so ein all in one
gerät und deswegen kann man da draußen
eigentlich schon alles auch mal zu
bereiten uns schmeckt halt schon anders
man hat halt einfach diesen diesen
grillgeschmack mit dabei und es macht
spaß auto ja sehr gut also macht's gut
bis zum nächsten mal probiert das rezept
gerne auf und schreibt mir gerne was ihr
euch als nächstes mal tschüss
[Musik]